على سبيل المثال لدينا هنا هيئه الطرق
والمواصلات ينظر سيف العليلي الى المستقبل
نظرا لكونه مديرا تنفيذيا لمؤسسه دبي
لمتحف المستقبل يمل على ان تحقق دبي هدفها
وان تصبح مدينه ذكيه رائده بحلول العام
2021 نعمل على جمع التمويل من المجتمع
لتشجيع الابتكار جمع التمويل بهدف
الابتكار هكذا تامل دبي مواجهه التحديات
الاقتصاديه في المستقبل من خلال اختيار
افضل الشركات الناشئه من حول العالم وحثها
على العمل بشكل مباشر مع الهيئات الحكوميه
كل هذا يحصل تحت سقف واحد هنا في منظومه
مسرعات دبيل للمستقبل بصرف النظر عما اذا
كانت سيارات بلا سائق او ثلاجات تبرد
ذاتيا او مختبرات افتراضيه سويشي ستورت
اودا هو مؤسس مشارك في شركه الكا لايف
التي تتخذ من الصين مقرا لها امضينا
الكثير من الوقت لمحاوله جعل هذا الشيء
مستداما قر
تعمل هذه الشركه الناشئه المختصه بالطعام
ييدا بيد مع بلديه دبي على امل ايجاد
الحلول لمواجهه تحديات الامن الغذائي مثل
ندره المياه والشركات الناشئه ليست وحدها
المهتمه بايجاد الحلول المستقبليه اذ تسعى
غيرها من الشركات المبتكره الى اللحاق
بالركب ايضا واسست مؤخرا حضانه الاعمال
انكيت 1776 والتي تتخذ من الولايات
المتحده مقرا لها اول مركز دولي لها هنا
بالنسبه لنا القدره على جعل دبي مختبرا
حيا وعملاق لجذب هذه الشركات الناشئه كان
امرا في غايه الاثاره ووضعت دبي اهدافا قد
يراها البعض طموحه الى حد بعيد لكن رغم
وجود بعض المصاعب يبدو ان هناك اهتماما
كبيرا من قبل المستثمرين